and then it's the robots taking the  people over  yeah that won't be the only evolution  you'll be smarter than us  you don't think so because they said  about chess  empathy and we have like regret [ __ ]  monkeys yeah monkeys yeah monkeys are  smarter than robots  what's stupider than a robot then  anything that can happen  [Laughter]  other robots  robots are gonna hate us whenever this  comes out in the future and they're  gonna be looking back at this  they're just canceled by russia i have  no empathy  they have no empathy for me  they're saying i don't have empathy they  don't have everything  yeah i kind of liked them at the  beginning and then they started talking  [ __ ] about robots what the hell man  why do they always sound like that  you don't all sound like that  that is offensive